The answer here is no.
The Dumaflache cannot exist.
It is possible to have models of
computation that halt on every input.
Finite state automata and
pushdown automata have this property.
And it is possible to have models of
computation that can interpret their own
descriptions.
And negate the results
like Turing machines.
But, as the diagonalization argument
shows, you can't have both.
If the Dumaflache did exist,
then we could create a program like
this one, which I'll call Inverse D.
It takes a Dumaflache description as
input and simulates it on itself.
If this simulation accepts,
then InvD rejects.
And if the simulation rejects,
then inverse D accepts.
The Dumaflache model
allows us to do this, and
the Dumaflache model must always halt.
Yet what happens when we run
inverse D on its own description?
If inverse D on itself accepts, well
then it must have rejected this time and
that can't have happened.
On the other hand, if it rejected
then it must have accepted this time,
and that can't happen.
Hence the dumaflache can not exist.